you may have heard the flutter is almost
like magic when it comes to building
native apps so you decided to jump on
the flutter train but now you find
yourself
refactoring this giant nested nightmare
of widgets luckily flutter has a whole
bunch of tricks up its sleeve so you
should never have to battle with code
like this in today's video we'll look at
12 different strategies for building
efficient and maintainable flutter apps
if you're new here like and subscribe
and leave a comment below for a chance
to win this t-shirt or my first trick
I'll show you how to write code
automatically using nothing but the tab
key in the mouse I talked about this in
detail in my full flutter course which
you can access as a pro member but there
are a few things that you absolutely
must know if we take a look at this code
snippet you can see a lot of closing
tags on a single line making it very
hard to understand but you can easily
fix this by adding trailing commas to
your arguments and lists and the end
result is an easy to read tree structure
when we format the file but doing this
manually all the time would get really
annoying that's why you should get
really good at using the tab key because
the tooling is so good in dart and
flutter that almost everything can be
auto-completed with intellisense just
hover over the thing you want hit tab
and the trailing column will be added
for you
[Music]
but the most powerful tool you have at
your disposal is the refactor tool it
allows us to insert new widgets into the
widget tree especially commonly used
ones like container and center and we
can also use it to remove widgets
without having to think about where the
opening and closing characters are and
if the widget tree starts to become too
deeply nested that usually means we need
to refactor out into our own state list
or stateful widget and the refactor tool
can easily handle that while also
setting up a constructor with the
necessary input properties so you should
really never have to write a custom
widget from scratch now tip number two I
learned from Robert Brune heggs YouTube
channel which you should definitely be
subscribed to if you're using flutter
you won't be able to use the vs code
refactor tool in every situation but
there's still a few things you can do to
make your life easier first install the
awesome flutter snippets from gnash rom
dial that will give you shortcuts to
generate things like stateful and
stateless widgets then when you run into
issues with your code you can hit
control period to run a quick fix a
common example is when you're adding
properties to a class and you want to
add the properties to the constructor
along with a key in many cases control
period will fix your code with a single
keystroke and another tip from Robert is
to use the bracket pair colorizer plugin
to visually match the opening and
closing characters between widgets
adding additional clarity to your editor
using your tools effectively is one
thing but now let's look into some of
the magic tricks that are built into the
flutter framework itself flutter renders
animations beautifully at 60fps or
better but animations traditionally
require a lot of complex code animated
container is a widget that you can apply
styles to just like a regular container
but if those Styles change then it will
automatically animate in between them
you can animate things like position
size color shadow and gradients just to
name a few and all you have to do as a
developer is provide the duration and
timing curve of that animation then to
find some dynamic properties on the
widget and when those properties change
flutter will automatically animate
between them so the animations can be
implicitly tied to the underlying data
or state of the application and that
brings me to tip number four Dart
it might not be the most exciting
programming language in the world but it
has some nice sugary features that can
make your code concise and readable one
of my favorite features is the ability
to add conditional logic and for loops
directly inside of lists let's imagine
we have this button and we want to
animate five different box shadows
simultaneously we could animate each of
these shadows one by one or we could
simply combine an animated container
along with some conditional logic and a
for loop inside of a list and we're done
so once you understand how to use these
tricks you can combine them together to
get things done even faster but flutter
can actually provide even more magic
when it comes to animating between
screens using the hero widget if you
look closely here you can see that the
image that we click on it never actually
leaves the screen even though we're
moving to a completely different screen
so the users focus is never broken and
it just looks really nice and polished
to make this animation happen you just
need to have two screens that you switch
between using a navigator and you wrap
the part of the UI that's shared between
the two screens usually an image using
the hero widget both instances of the
hero will share a common tag and flutter
will match these two tags together and
handle all the animation stuff for you
under the hood but what if you have
something super complex like a fully
animated 2d vector scene and you want
the user to be able to interact with
those graphics tip number six is flare
which is a 2d animation tool that allows
you to integrate complex animations
directly in your flutter app and one of
the best practical demos that I've seen
using player comes from the filled Stax
YouTube channel which is a must
subscribe for flutter developers in that
tutorial he shows you how to create the
animations in Flair's design tool and
then export them and make them
interactive in a flutter app at 60fps
now I've mentioned 60fps a couple times
now because it's so important for the
user experience but how do you know if
your app and your animations are
actually hitting this benchmark flutter
actually has a built in performance
profiling tool that you can use on an
actual device
to determine how well your apps
performing now this only works on
physical devices and not emulators but
you simply run your app from the command
line using the profile flag and enter
capital P and that will show this
overlay on your device if you see any
red bars as you're using the app then
you know that you have a performance
bottleneck that needs to be addressed
somewhere now that you know you have
beautiful animations at 60fps you might
want to tweak things based on the
platform you're targeting flutter ships
with two widget libraries out of the box
material and Cupertino designed to look
perfect on Android and iOS most of the
apps that I've worked on have a very
customized UI but there are times where
you might want widgets to look like they
came directly from the platform itself
especially when it comes to dialogues
forms and alerts and it's also worth
noting that flutter is starting to
target the web Windows and Mac OS and
platform checking gives us a way to
customize the experience without having
to duplicate all of our code for every
single app as an example if you have a
widget that should look different on iOS
than it does on Android you can simply
wrap it in your own stateless widget and
then do platform checking to show the
material widget on Android and the
Cupertino widget on iOS both widget
libraries share a very similar API so in
most cases you just need to separate
them with some basic conditional logic
and if that weren't easy enough a lot of
flutter widgets include this adaptive
static method on it which will do all
the platform checking and conditional
rendering for you automatically now
let's switch gears into builders when
you first get into flutter development
you'll see the word build or builder a
lot and a builder is just a function
that returns a widget if you've ever
used something like react Jas this
should feel very familiar because it
gives you a declarative way to describe
the entire UI now the really cool thing
about flutter is that a lot of the
widgets will allow you to directly pass
in a list for example a ListView which
gives you a scrollable list of items and
you can create that by just passing in a
static list of widgets but in many cases
you'll need to build your UI more
dynamically and what you'll find is that
a lot of widgets like ListView have a
builder method and this allows you to
define a builder function that will be
called every time the user Scrolls and
that gives you access to the current
index so you can describe exactly what
should be shown in the UI based on that
index and that's extremely powerful if
you have an infinitely long list or you
need to do something like server-side
pagination but the magic doesn't even
stop there
the ListView also has a static method
called separated and it works just like
the builder except it also gives you
access to build a divider in-between
the items and that's incredibly useful
if you need to group and divide items in
a specific way at runtime so flutter
does all kinds of amazing stuff for you
out of the box but one thing it doesn't
really have a strong opinion on is state
management it gives us a few low-level
building blocks like a stateful widget
and inherited widget but most apps are
going to need more than just these
building blocks but before you just go
and jump into a big complicated state
management solution I recommend applying
the proven software design paradigm of
keep it simple and there are two
libraries that stand out in my
experience with flutter that helped me
do that the first library is get it and
one of the things it does is allow you
to create a global singleton that can be
shared throughout the widget tree I find
it especially useful when working with
broadcast streams because you can create
the stream once and then use it in
multiple widgets even if they're on
completely different screens or in
completely different parts of the widget
tree get it should feel very natural if
you've ever used something like
dependency injection and angular
although that's not a perfect one-to-one
comparison and the other state
management solution that I really like
is provider which is a little more
similar to the context API and react but
the reason that I really like provider
is that it's mostly just syntactic sugar
for things like inherited widget and
stream builder which are built into
flutter natively and on top of that it
works really well with firebase which I
made an entire video about a couple
weeks ago and it's the state management
solution that I use in the fire ship
quiz app and the way it works is very
simple you declare a provider at one
point in the widget tree and you can
access that data and also react to
changes in a deeply nested child so
provider will solve a lot of your state
management problems without a ton of
boilerplate now hopefully you can use
these eleven tricks that we've looked at
to build a production ready app but once
you get to that point there's going to
be one less annoint hurdle to get over
and that of course is generating your
app icons for both iOS and Android if
you run into a challenge during
development chances are somebody else
has already faced that same challenge
and open sourced their solution and
that's exactly the case when it comes to
generating your launcher icons
this packages a command-line tool if
that only requires you to save one
single image in your flutter assets and
then will automatically generate all the
icons for both iOS and Android for you
and that's a hell of a lot easier than
trying to do it by hand from a design
program I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there this video helped you
please like and subscribe and consider
becoming a pro member on fire ship IO to
get access to the full flutter
course and if you have additional
flutter tips let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]